[Musique]
une visite très attendue à la fois
emblématique est historique
accompagné d'un imposant dispositif de
sécurité
dix mille policiers et militaires
déployés dans la capitale irakienne pour
assurer la sécurité du pape françois et
de son cortège dès son tout premier
discours en sol irakien
le souverain pontife a déclaré que la
guerre et les attaques devait cesser nos
gènes et limiter les défauts sûr que se
taisent les armes at il proclamé que
leur diffusion soit limitée ici et
partout
un appel à la coexistence pacifique des
différents groupes ethniques et
religieux le pape françois qui est
reconnu pour sa proximité avec le public
a dû limiter les bains folle en raison
de la pandémie
bien que le pontife de 84 ans et
l'ensemble de sa délégation
ecclésiastiques et journalistique est
tous été vaccinés avant le voyage
mais la foule bien suffi rationnés il
s'est rendu dans une cathédrale de
bagdad où plus de 50 chrétiens ont été
abattus lors d'une prise d'otages en
2010 l'occasion de rencontrer des
fidèles et des membres du clergé car la
venue du pape françois en irak
représente une lueur d'espoir pour la
population
coincé entre la résurgence du nombre de
cas de coronavirus et la flambée de
violence qui affligent le pays
ici julie aimant radio canada montréal